وفقا لقائمه مجله تايم اوت لافضل مدن
العالم التي تعتمد على استطلاع راي يشمل
اكثر من 20,000 شخص من مختلف مدر العالم
احتلت المدينه الحمراء مراكش المرتبه
السابعه لتكون المدينه العربيه الوحيده في
قائمه افضل عشر مدن في العالم حسب مؤشر
المجله الشهيره متقدمه بهذا التصنيف على
اشهر المدن العالميه وكان ترتيب المدن
التالي اولا ادم را في اسكتلندا التي
احتلت مرتبه عاليه في جميع المجالات منها
اكثر المدن التي يمكن السير فيها على
الاقدام جاءت مدينه شيكاغو في الولايات
المتحده في المرتبه الثانيه ثم مدينه في
كولومبيا وجلاسكو في اسكتلندا وفي المرتبه
الخامسه جاءت امستردام فيه هولندا ثم
مدينه تشيك ثلاثه في المغرب وبرلين في
المانيا
في كندا كانت المرتبه العاشره من نصيب
كوبنهاجن
لميس المزيد حول باختيار مراكش والذات في
هذه القائمه
[موسيقى]
التي لقبت بالمدينه الحمراء تعتبر من اهم
الاجهات السياحيه في العالم العربي وهذه
ابرز معالم مراكش التي تسقطب السياح ساحه
جامع الفن التي شهيدت في نفس عهد التشييد
المدينه في القرن الخامس الميلادي سوق
مراكش مما تجريه المتنوعه التي تقدم التحف
والانتكات النادره والملابس الشعبيه
بالاضافه الى السوق الحرفيين المخصص
للصناعات اليدويه التقليديه حديقه ماجوريل
وهي حديقه رائعه تستقبل محبين النباتات
والازهار النادره قصر الباهيه وهو من
المعالم التاريخيه المميزه بالمدينه ومتحف
افالون حيث يجد محبي الموضه متعتهم اثناء
زيارته ومتحف درس الصعيد ويعتبر تحفه
معماريه تستحق ان تكون ضمن اهم المعالم
السياحيه في مراكش للراغبين بالتعرف على
العماره المغربيه المدينه القديمه او كما
يطلق عليها اسم المدينه العتيقه ضمت الى
قائمه اليونسكو ولترات العالمي لكونها احد
مواقع التراث ذات الاهميه التاريخيه
الكبيره مسجد الكتيبه وحي القصبه التي
يمثل تاريخ المدينه وعظمتها بهذا المسجد
العتيق يتميز بتجل العماره الاسلاميه التي
تظهر بصوره واضحه على الابنيه القديمه
بمدينه مراكش العتيقه حي المدابغ ويمكن
زيارته للتعرف على كيفيه صناعه المنتجات
الجلديه
[موسيقى]
وينورنا في الاستديو محمد العلي صانع
محتوى متخصص في السفر محمد يسعد صباحك
مدامنا نحكي عن اجمل مدن العالم ما هي
المعايير التي يبحث عليها السياح والزوار
لاختيار مدن العالم تمام اولا صباح الخير
الناس دائما لما يروحوا للسفر او يدورونا
تختلف عندهم المعايير وخاصه زاد عندنا
معيار كذلك الماضيه كثير من الناس تدور
اول السهوله الوصول للمكان من ناحيه الفيز
الامور هذه الرسميات ثاني شيء شيء رئيس
كثير اللي هو طبيعه المكان والجو الموجود
في المكان هذا
الامان في المكان هذا التواصل اللغه مع
الناس الحضاره الموجوده في المكان هذا شو
الاشياء هذه اللي ممكن تخليهم انا ممكن
اطلع من دولتي اروح مكان ثاني اعيش تجربه
كامله مختلفه عن اللي عايش لنا وارجع
بذكريات واشياء حلوه وكذلك هدايا تذكاريه
بقت بالنهار اكيد طيب محمد يعني هاي فكره
تصنيفات افضل واجمل يعني كانه فيها نوع من
السرياليه لان الموضوع نسبي نوعا ما خصوصا
بس بحكم خبرتك في السفر وتعدد البلدان
التي زرتها هل يمكن الحديث عن بلد انه هي
فعلا اجمل مدينه او افضل من غيرها لا يجب
على كل انسان ان يزورها يوما ما همم
الموضوع شو الاحلى واللي مش احلى هذا نسبي
للشخص ممكن ان يكون همم له نظره انه مكان
هذا جميل لان مثلا محمد العلي احب مكان
يكون فيه ثقافه اروح المكان هذا حصه في
ثقافه حصل فيه تراث حصل في تاريخ شيء جميل
بالنسبه لي ممكن اي شخص ثاني يقول لا انا
هالاشياء ما تهمني انا يهمني في ماركات
ممكن اشتري في اماكن همم يعني همم ممكن
همم اترفع فيها همم كل شخص همم معيار معين
ولكن بالنسبه لي اشوف المكان لتاريخ
وللثقافه اذا جمعت الثقافه والتاريخ مع
الناس ثقافه مع بعض مزز همم عملت مزيج
بينهم راح يطلع لك شيء مميز المكان هذا
يميز عن اي مكان ثاني وما تقدرين تخلقين
مثل البيئه هذه في اي دوله ثانيه طيب
المعايير ذكرتها انت تحديدا محمد شو
الاماكن اللي زرتها فيها معالم تاريخيه
فيها طبيعه خلابه وخلاتك تفكر تزورها مره
ثانيه همم كثير همم
مثل يعني مثلا تكلمت عن اللسته هذه همم
عندكم مثلا ابراج همم يعني بالكلام عن لها
تاريخ عريق جدا همم والحضاره والابنيه
اللي فيها شيء جميل جدا الموجود فيها من
ناحيه ان انتم ممكن تتخلي لنا المكان هذا
وتمشين فيه مجرد المشي ومحتاج ان اركب
سياره ولا قطاره او اي شيء واشوف الجماليه
اللي في المكان هذا واشوف التاريخ اللي
فيها كذلك عندنا مثلا ذكرنا بالسته همم
مراكش المكتبه السابعه همم
طبعا ارتفع ااا ال ال التقييم مالها السنه
هذه لسبب معين السبب ان بعد الجائحه طلعوا
كثير من رواد الاعمال في مراكش وبدو
يشتغلون على مشاري صحيح صحيح مطاعم حديثه
بدون ناس يطلعون بمشاريع كيف ممكن همم
يطورون صوره مراكش داخليا وخارجيا عشان
يجذبون الناس لها فهي الشيء رفع جدا من
معدل التقييم لها فمحمد اليوم ماذا تنصح
لمن يرغب بان يكون مدون صفار ترافلوجر
اول شيء ابحث عن شغل شو تبغى في نفسك لان
عندنا المجال البلوجين في السفر او توثيق
السفر مش بعد جدا من الناس اللي تروح فقط
تصور اماكن وتعرضها مجرد عرض لكن انت اذا
تبغى تروح وتعرض همم همم اماكن للسفر حدد
انت شو تبي تعرض في السفر هذا هل انت تبحث
فقط مثلا عن اماكن تراثيه هل تبحث انت عن
الاسواق هل تبحث عن الاكل في ناس متخصصين
اكل فانت لما تدور شغفك في السفر هذا من
السفر راح يطلع للناس مش مجرد الاماكن
الازوره وتعرض للناس شكرا جزيلا نورتنا في
الاستديو محمد علي صالح متخصص في السفر
نورتنا محمد شكرا